il riscaldamento globale è un fatto è
semplicemente l'innalzamento della
temperatura media della terra negli
ultimi 150 anni
è un fatto perché lo si vede da questo
grafico che mostra l'anomalia cioè la
variazione della temperatura media
terrestre
negli ultimi duemila anni si vede
evidentemente come a partire dall'anno
zero per i primi 1800 anni
questa variazione è stata vicina allo
zero ha seguito un andamento naturale
poi da un certo punto nel 1880 bam una
rampa incontrollata è un fatto è un
fatto e adesso siamo a milano e ottobre
e ci sono 20 gradi con la su cui alcuni
pochissimi in realtà non sono d'accordo
e sull'origine sulla causa antropica di
questo riscaldamento ma per capire come
mai invece la totalità della comunità
scientifica praticamente la pensa così
pensa che sia l'uomo ad aver determinato
questo incremento
bisogna ricordare cos'è l'effetto serra
l'effetto serra non è nient'altro che
una coperta una cappa di co2 sul nostro
pianeta nella nostra atmosfera che
intrappola i raggi solari
l'energia solare nella nostra biosfera e
quindi l'energia entra
rimane e non riesce a essere dispersa
nello spazio freddo e aumenta la
temperatura
cosa c'entra la co2 la co2 il gas che
determina questa cappa questa coperta e
ed è il motivo per cui è l'uomo la causa
di questo fenomeno
noi stiamo immettendo troppa co2
nell'atmosfera
e la prova di questo la prova
schiacciante che la comunità scientifica
ci ha fornito e questo grafico che fa
vedere come negli ultimi 800 mila anni
la concentrazione di co2 nel nostro
pianeta ha sempre seguito un andamento
regolare fino a 200 anni fa in cui anche
qui bam un'altra rampa un'altra crescita
incontrollata
lì c'è stata la seconda rivoluzione
industriale c'è stato l'uomo
e come mai stiamo mettendo così tanta
co2 da dove viene tutta questa co2 ci
aiuta quest'altro grafico a torta questa
volta in cui si vede che il 70 per cento
quindi la stragrande maggioranza della
co2 che noi mettiamo nell'atmosfera
deriva da la produzione di energia
energia che ci serve per alimentare
supportare farci crescere e per
supportare tutte le attività umane che
noi svolgiamo sul pianeta
quindi central uomo come facciamo a
ridurre tutto ciò come facciamo a far
rientrare questa crescita incontrollata
non sarà una lampadina led a salvarci e
come dire che non so io voglio dimagrire
però andando tutti i giorni al fast food
e ordinando il caffè senza lo zucchero
oltre il 70 per cento delle emissioni di
co2
la nostra società derivano dalla
produzione di energia ma quando abbiamo
iniziato a produrre così tanta energia e
quindi così tanta co2 perché bisogna
tornare indietro alla fine del 1700
quando james watt in inghilterra è
inventato la macchina a vapore
tutto parte dalla macchina a vapore che
inizialmente era una soluzione un
problema ben specifico dovevano tirare
fuori l'acqua le infiltrazioni d'acqua
dalle miniere e prima lo facevano le
persone intimi minatori con dei secchi
mettendosi l'acqua dosso e faticando la
macchina a vapore stata la soluzione a
quel problema
la cosa curiosa è che la soluzione di un
problema è diventata poi gradualmente
motore di crescita motore di profitto
quando l'umanità ha scoperto che poteva
bruciare risorse naturali come il
carbone la legna combustibili fossili
per trasformarli in lavoro utile
eccoli è successo qualcosa di unico
nella storia dell'umanità su questa
possibilità si è fondato un nuovo
sistema economico
il capitalismo che per definizione si
basa sulla proprietà di mezzi di
produzione sulla tecnologia quindi la
macchina a vapore col fine di
utilizzarla per produrre profitto
crescita crescita un po fine a se stessa
possiamo dire una crescita che è
incontrollata e che si vede anche nei
grafici della demografia della
popolazione mondiale
se vediamo questo grafico anche qui è
identico praticamente a quelli della
temperatura della
ho visto prima una linea orizzontale che
poi a un certo punto impazzisce
impazzisce negli ultimi questa volta 50
70 anni quando mia madre è nata nel 1950
in questo mondo eravamo due miliardi e
mezzo di persone nella sua vita adesso a
circa 70 anni siamo diventati 8 miliardi
di persone
un per tre in 70 anni quando in due
milioni di anni erano arrivati a 2
miliardi e mezzo un qualcosa di
incredibile e questa cosa è conclamata e
insostenibile
più siamo più consumiamo risorse più
emettiamo co2 più
semplifichiamo il problema dell'effetto
serra e quindi andiamo a sciogliere i
ghiacciai perché aumenta la temperatura
aumentano i livelli dei mari
le terre diventano secche c'è il
problema della siccità si riduce la
percentuale di terra disponibile per la
vita si riduce la disponibilità di terra
disponibile per la coltivazione quindi
meno cibo ma noi siamo sempre di più
andiamo incontro a una vera e propria
crisi demografica ma siamo veramente
fritti
in realtà c'è una speranza ma se è vero
che il capitalismo è intimamente
connesso al global warming è veramente
difficile pensare che questa speranza
che sia da nella fine del capitalismo
non è ragionevole pensare che i ceo
delle più grandi multinazionali da un
momento all'altro cambino completamente
le proprie strategie accettando di
diventare dei martiri ambientali non è
ragionevole pensare che la politica sia
l'unico modo per innescare questo
processo
basta pensare agli stati uniti che hanno
deciso di uscire dagli accordi di parigi
negli accordi in cui tanti paesi si
erano messi insieme per decidere di
risolvere il problema del global warming
non è possibile pensarlo io credo che la
soluzione risiede nel ricambio
generazionale a cui stiamo andando
incontro
un ricambio generazionale che porterà in
posizioni di potere di decisione delle
persone dei giovani che sono cresciuti
in un contesto completamente diverso da
quello degli anni 70 80 diverso da
quello in cui sono cresciuti baby boomer
che avevano davanti un economia in
fortissima inarrestabile crescita
un'economia in cui non si parlava tanto
di
temi ambientali come si fa oggi
un'economia in cui sostanzialmente c'era
molto meno incertezza molto meno rischio
noi giovani di adesso di 20 30 anni nati
negli anni novanta negli anni 2000
dobbiamo accettare il rischio come una
componente naturale del nostro futuro
e questa cosa è una difficoltà è un
qualcosa che ci rende più difficile
progettare il nostro futuro ma
dall'altra parte ci rende molto più
inclini a rischiare è una generazione
che è pronta a rischiare è una
generazione ad altissimo potenziale
noi dobbiamo partire da questo per
ricordarci che è tutto sulle nostre
spalle e soprattutto che saremo noi a
dover pensare modelli di business
all'interno di questo sistema economico
che saranno sostenibili non solo
economicamente ma anche ambientalmente è
un nostro imperativo morale
la bella notizia è che esistono ormai
evidenze concrete reali del fatto che
questi modelli che hanno una
sostenibilità sia economica che
ambientale funzionano lasciare in
economy
la circular economy sono solamente due
esempi che ormai sono pervasivi nelle
nostre vite e ci sono start up aziende
nuove che stanno mettendo in forte
difficoltà dei colossi mangiando mercato
a queste multinazionali e quindi
dimostrando che non è solamente un
qualcosa di possibile a livello
ambientale ma è anche conveniente a
livello economico
noi dobbiamo partire
in questo contesto sbagliando provando
rialzandoci e poi alla fine riuscendoci
noi dobbiamo essere quelli che decidono
di alzarsi dalla propria poltrona in
ufficio per provare a fare qualcosa di
nuovo per provare a salvare il mondo
fondando la nostra azienda andando a
lavorare in un'azienda con questa
missione aprendo un'azienda agricola in
umbria
tutte queste cose indeboliscono il
vecchio sistema quello che ci ha portato
dove siamo oggi e foraggiano un modello
nuovo sistema con una nuova mentalità
quella giusta per risolvere finalmente
questo problema enorme che ci troviamo
davanti abbiamo bisogno di persone che
abbiano la voglia di fare tutto ciò e
perché no di divertirsi anche da morire
nell'impresa